الجيش البريطاني نفذ عمليات سريه في
اوكرانيا حسبما كشف جنرال بريطاني لصحيفه
تايمز المسؤول البريطاني قالل الصحيفه ان
وحدات المارينز الملكيه وهي وحدات النخبه
في البحريه البريطانيه في عمليات سريه
شديده الحساسيه وتنطوي على مستوى عال من
المخاطر العسكريه والسياسيه الضابط اوضح
انه تم ارسال 350 من مشات البحريه من وحده
النخبه 45 لمرافقه الدبلوماسيين من
السفاره البريطانيه في وقت سابقا من
العامه بينما كانت القوات الروسيه تحشد
للهجوم على اوكرانيا وفي وقت لاحقا عادت
وحده النخبه الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه في
ابريلا لضمان امن السفاره عندما كانت
المملكه المتحده تعيد ترتيب تمثيل
هديبلوماسي بعد انسحاب القوات الروسيه من
محيطك في ذلك الوقت اقرت وزاره الدفاع في
لندن بارسال قوات كوماندوز تحياتي افراد
السفاره لكنها قالت ان عددهم لا يتجاوز 30
جنديا ليتبين اللاحقا ان العدد 10 اضعاف
الرقم المعلن ويعد الاعلان من قبل القائد
السابق روبرت ماغوان اول ضابط كبير يعترف
بمشاركه القوات البريطانيه في عمليات خاصه
في اوكرانيا واشار وان الى ان الجنود
الذين تم نشرهم تم ارسالهم من شمال
البعثه الدبلوماسيه فيكاف الى بولندا
[موسيقى]